I'm sure we've all,
at one point in our lives,
watched or read
an anime or manga
that we've really felt
we had a connection with.
Something that spoke to us
on a deeper level
for whatever reason that may be.
Perhaps it reminded us of
an experience we had in our lives
or conveyed a message
where you really understood
or had some characters
you could totally empathize with.
Because of it, we ended up
growing a deep attachment
to the point where no matter what
flaws the thing might actually have,
we could easily overlook it because...
well, it didn't matter.
It didn't affect our experience
or why we got so attached to it.
And even if others
did find flaws with it,
we didn't care.
As, they didn't have the same
experience that you did.
To us, it was perfect.
Even if, objectively speaking,
The perfect anime, the perfect game,
the perfect movie
cannot exist.
Recently, I was lucky enough
to be able to see
the record-breaking
𝘠𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘕𝘢𝘮𝘦 in theaters
and it absolutely
blew me away.
So much so, I had to
watch it, not twice,
but 3 times before
getting close to satisfied.
And it was after I walked
out of the theater for the third time
that I knew I'd found
my new perfect anime.
Except, I know that,
critically speaking,
if I called this "perfect,"
or "a masterpiece,"
or any other overly
superlative adjective,
there would be those of us who would argue
the semantics of describing it such a way
'cause, at the end of the day,
it's an opinion that's subjective.
And I don't know why this word
is so looked down upon
when we're talking
critically about something.
Of course I know if a film isn't perfect.
The characters aren't the deepest,
moments of it can play off melodrama,
and I'm sure if I thought deeply about it,
I can find plot holes
because the film
speaks to the heart
rather than to the mind.
Though, none of that
actually matters to me
because I felt it achieved
everything it need to,
and there's so much I love about this film
that I wouldn't change
a single thing about it.
I can't remember the last time I saw
something with so much charm and beauty to it
and there's just not one,
single thing I can point at
to say why I love this movie.
The beautiful dichotomy of
two star-crossed lovers
learning vicariously about one another.
capturing the care-free
nature of adolescence
like that melancholic feeling of watching
a long summer's day passing by.
That dreamlike quality
of longing for something
that seems preordained yet lost
while mixing in themes like
fantasy, long-distance relationships,
and natural disaster somehow
weaving all this into a compelling narrative.
There are so many elements
blending together
to create a piece of work that
spoke to me on so many levels
that went beyond
just breaking down
characters, animation,
writing, and music.
I walked out of the theater
with that same bittersweet joy
of meeting a lost friend
you won't see again for a long time
with a reignited passion
for this medium I love so much,
and that's not one thing you can just
put on a 1-to-10 review scale.
To me, it was a masterpiece.
And no amount of plot holes,
character writing, or melodrama
could take that away from me.
But I know that not everyone
will share the same experience I did
or come to the same conclusion.
There will be people it didn't appeal to.
Some will have gotten
too caught up in the hype,
or simply couldn't connect to it
as much for whatever reason,
and that's fine.
No one will ever create
a piece of work
that would appeal to
absolutely everybody,
so why is it that we
pretend a good review
is something that can
objectively break down
what makes a piece of media
good or not?
Many self-proclaimed critics I've seen
always harp back to the
writing and characters
as the absolute backbone
of what makes something good.
As if there's only one specific
formula to making a great show.
Which is something I totally disagree with.
Sure there is a guidebook and theories
to what makes good
film making and story telling,
which applies to the majority,
but we shouldn't forget what they are.
A guide. Not an absolute.
And there are exceptions to every rule.
Every anime sets out to
achieve something different
and part of the charm of certain movies or shows
is the way they are able to impress you
even if it clearly has flaws.
Or sometimes even embracing them.
We say show, don't tell. Then along comes the Monogatari series
showing us that we can craft an interesting story
almost entirely through dialogue.
If characters and writing were all that mattered,
then we wouldn't get things like the mind-blowing visual
extravaganza that was Redline.
Gurren Lagann came to celebrate the cheesy heroic tropes
we all thought we were tired of.
And the ending of Evangelion was such a raw, unfiltered outcry of emotion
that love it or hate it - has remained a topic of discussion
and a resonating moment for many people to this day.
So what is it that really makes the show mean something to us?
The conclusion I've come to is that there is no single
technique that portrays this
but there is a common driving force I have felt from all these shows:
Passion and communication.
At the end of the day, anime is a form of art.
A way for the creators to communicate to the audience in some way.
Whether it be an idea, a feeling, an experience or something else.
And my favorite shows are the ones where this communication really resonated with me.
Maybe was a hype scene, a beautiful
moment a genius piece of writing.
And I'm sure you all have your own personal examples.
Which is why I feel like the best critics are people who can break down why a movie or anime appeals to them,
and what aspect of it would appeal to an
individual audience member.
Rather than a blanket statement of why it's objectively
good.
Nothing about this is objective. So
instead of condemning subjectivity, why
aren't we embracing it?
Most of my favorite ever shows had
nothing to do with ticking off some
predetermined categories,
But some aspects of feeling that I really liked about it.
Recently I've seen an increase in people embracing the critical analysis of anime, which is great you know.
There's nothing wrong with promoting a smarter way of looking at a medium.
But I think in doing so, I feel
we've created a community that upholds
having a higher knowledge and appreciation of the inner workings behind your favorite shows more than
just having fun.
It is possible to embrace critical thinking while acknowledging the subjectivity of it.
So we may a joke about it but there's certainly no such thing as a bad taste in anime.
In fact I think the worst thing you can do is either keep a closed mind or alter your taste so it's more  respectable.
I've seen far too many
people try to hide their actual taste
because they think it's too mainstream or two trashy or something that isn't critically acclaimed.
There's nothing wrong with your favorite anime,
even if it doesn't take all the boxes and characters or writing or cinematography
or if you just like it for some really
stupid reason.
And it's definitely nothing wrong with thinking some critically acclaimed shows are just   boring as hell.
if you can unashamedly say, hey i just really like this trashy show because it was trashy.
all the more power to you.
I unashamedly hold "love hina" close to me because
it reminds me of a time when, my adolescence romanticize the concept of just finding a partner who would accept me.
And every so often another show comes along it just appeals to that side of me
even if I know it's absolutely trashy.
Your taste reflect who you are as a person, your interests are shaped by your experiences,
and upbringing that made you the individual you are today.
So why the hell shouldn't you be proud
of that?
It shouldn't be about having superior taste,
it shouldn't be about showing off how much
knowledge you have.
And it definitely shouldn't be about showing how much smarter you are than other people.
It should be about keeping an open mind, embracing individuality,
and most of all having fun!
I'm the type of guy who can be groping
at the complex narrative presentation
seen in Satoshi Kon's work,
and then arguing over which Monogatari girl has the most appealing bust in the same conversation.
In fact those were some of the most interesting conversations I've ever had.
With some of the most interesting
people I've ever had the pleasure of
meeting.
Whatever shows hold a special place in your heart, are special because that's the person you are.
so don't forget that.
and I guess all I really wanted to say through all this mindless rambling without any real point I was trying to make was that
I saw an anime the other day
and I liked it a lot. It was pretty great.
No...
In fact, it was perfect.
[Beautiful music plays]
[The End]